i got engaged wait what
i got engaged aaron rodgers casually
dropped
that bombshell on saturday during the
nfl honors broadcast on
cbs and according to multiple reports
the green bay packers quarterback's
fiancee is shailene
woodley 2020 was definitely a crazy year
filled with lots of change growth some
amazing memorable moments
i got engaged and i played some of the
best football in my career
so i'd like to thank my team off the
field my fiance
the 37 year old nfl star didn't name the
actress during his acceptance speech for
the most valuable player award
but news did break that he was dating
the big little lies star
less than a week before he revealed his
engagement
i don't think about necessarily how
other people are going to react to it
a source tells et that the two have
actually been a couple
for a few months now quote they have
been keeping their relationship
private for the most part but are very
into each other
it's really exciting to be able to share
this new chapter of it with the world
aaron and shaylene have yet to comment
on their romance
but back in september during his
appearance on the pat mcafee show
aaron said that he was having more fun
in life and was
focusing on love i have just
a new and increased love
of life and i've made decisions
and changes and habits that
put me in a lot better headspace and
there's just a lot of things that have
come together in my life
over the last few months that have
really been
enjoyable and reminded me giving me
perspective
on life and football to view things
through the most positive lens i
possibly can
and that's why i'm having so much fun
and it starts with love
prior to his relationship with the 29
year old actress
aaron dated race car driver danica
patrick
the former couple split last july after
spending
two years together the nfl star also
dated olivia munn for three years before
they broke up
in 2017. as for shailene
aaron isn't the only athlete she's dated
she was last linked to rugby player ben
bolavola
in 2018.
[Music]